hi this is presh talwalkar we'll start
out the proof by noticing that two
squared is equal to two plus two
or we're adding two to itself for a
total of two times
this pattern is true for other numbers
when we have 3 squared
that's the same as adding 3 to itself
for a total of 3 times
similarly
4 squared
is equal to four
added to itself for a total of four
times
in general
x squared is equal to x added to itself
for a total of x
times this is the equation that will be
the basis for our paradox
we'll start out with x squared is equal
to x added to itself for a total of x
times
now we're going to use some calculus
we're going to take the derivative
of each side
the derivative of x squared is equal to
2x on the right hand side the derivative
of x is equal to one
the derivative of x again is equal to
one
and then we keep adding this so each
time we add a one to the derivative of x
and we do this for a total of x times
if we add 1 to itself a total of x times
we find that 2x is equal to x
and this is a problem because this has
to be true for every value of x so it
doesn't matter if we put x equals one x
equals a half
we end up with the result that two is
equal to one
and this is strange because it seems
like every step we've done has been
valid but we've come to a contradictory
result
so can you figure it out
i bet if you pose this to your math
teacher
many times your math teacher won't know
exactly where the proof went wrong
but i'm going to show it to you so that
you can explain to your teacher why this
proof isn't correct
the beginning equation is correct x
squared is equal to x plus itself a
total of x times
when we take the derivative of x squared
we get 2x that's correct but the mistake
comes at this step when we take the
derivative of x added to itself x times
we cannot simply add each term one by
one by taking the derivative
and there's a reason for this when we
add x to itself a total of x times this
is not a simple linear equation where we
take the derivative of each term
we really have x times itself
so in order to compute the derivative of
x plus x a total of x times we really
have a sum that's involving x
so in order to take this derivative we
need to use the product rule
so we take
the first term times the derivative of
the second so we have x
times 1 plus the second term of x times
the derivative of the first term x to
get 1.
when we do it this way we find that 2x
is equal to 2x and of course this is
true
and so there's no paradox at all here
there's no contradiction
so the problem in the proof is you can't
simply take the derivative of each term
because it's not a simple linear
expression it's an expression of x that
involves a total of x times
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions
you can also follow that on facebook
patreon and google plus
you can also catch me at preshtalwalker
on twitter instagram tumblr and
pinterest
and please check out my books i've
written some pretty cool books about
math i think you'll enjoy them there's
some mental math tricks and math puzzles
and there's a bunch of game theory as
well
so check it out there's a link in the
video description and thanks for
watching